Stay with the planet was still in the,
uh,
and the overview background section of this class.
And so if you to say,
I think that we're going big picture.
You're right.
We're going big pitch right now and we're going to drill down.
But what I want to do is talk about where we are currently and two to do a uh,
a full treatment of that has of course,
absolutely impossible.
So I can do almost little more than metaphor.
Uh,
but let's,
let's try,
so this is a demonstration that maybe some of you saw,
but it's the earth and 10 seconds.
Okay?
What has happening it means while you're waiting for this,
I want you to take a deep breath and I want you to hold that breath.
I want you to do this.
Literally,
I want you to do it literally.
I want you to take a deep breath and watch her to hold it for 10 seconds.
10 seconds is very long,
but I want you to get a feel for what 10 seconds is.
Exhale.
That's 10 seconds.
We got 10 seconds.
You've got it locked in.
All right,
10 seconds.
42 children were born 40 in the poorest nations in the world.
10 seconds,
10 seconds.
4,100 worth of damage was done to the global economy through polluting,
close to waters,
and totaling 13 billion in year,
10 seconds,
119 tons of hazardous and toxic waste,
or out to the world.
10 seconds.
Two people died from drinking bad water.
A 1 billion don't have access to clean drinking water.
And 2 billion don't have access to sanitation.
Ah,
almost 4,000 tons of fuel consumed.
2000 tons of co two was added to the atmosphere.
2 billion people don't have access to electricity and pull a billion.
Don't have adequate supplies.
Furniture.
Three children died from preventable diseases,
malaria and ammonia,
measles,
malnutrition,
dysentery of the three children that die too,
to have babies.
And the last 10 seconds,
four acres of rainforest with destroyed.
All right.
So any one of those things is,
um,
is of concern.